[Music]
let's go to portland oregon next hannah
joins us there hannah how can we help
hi guys um thank you for having me i
wanted to ask um i have been following
dave ramsey since the beginning of this
year and i'm on baby step number three
hey my question was
my question was how
what is maybe the best way to get into
the dating scene
and follow dave ramsey's plan at the
same time like how do you talk to people
if you're interested in them about being
debt-free
and finding the right partner wow that's
a great question hannah why i have
thoughts on this one wow
i have some vlogs
but this is what's great
no ladies first and what i like is
hannah's going to get both sides of the
perspective here ladies first oh i'm
ready um
so hannah i don't feel like it needs to
be a conversation
right off the bat by any means
uh i think as you start dating and if
it's the if it's one person consistently
you're gonna pick up naturally
their spending habits probably how they
talk about stuff i mean money is such an
integral part of life so it's it's
naturally going to come up
in conversation and again even just you
being aware of
of how they're handling their money and
so as the as it gets
more serious though in a relationship
and you know
okay this is probably this is heading
towards marriage like i'm feeling it
then that's when conversations about
life in general i feel like get more
serious and a little bit more tangible
and that's everything from kids
money
uh if if you have a spiritual walk right
a faith story that that comes into play
i mean a lot of these things
naturally are gonna come up while you're
dating but i think as it gets serious
that's when you start to turn to say
okay how much are we on the same page um
because i i would not advise nor can
maybe you would that you like ask for
their
you know tax returns on like the first
date that's like all right tell me
everything i mean are you how much are
you investing in your 401k you know
those things are not natural
you know questions the beginning of a
relationship um have you had experience
hannah i'm just curious of
of dating and you're thinking though in
the back of your mind you're scared to
get into a relationship or you're unsure
what what what is the what's what's the
reason behind your question
well because i got divorced when i was
21 years old i
so there's that part of me that i hear
about these couples on here that's
growing and getting out of debt and
you know i want to be
close to that partner
whoever they are but i just want to make
sure that we are because you know dave
talks about it all the time money is you
know one of the biggest issues yep um
and that's my fear absolutely i just
want to find that right person
now hannah
i'm 25. okay so
awesome couple i'm just going to give
you i'm going to give you the dude
perspective and and then i'm going to
give you just kind of this financial
peace perspective on on moving forward
uh
so you don't want to talk about this
early on okay you might as if you're
going to talk about debt and budgets and
what do you think about money on a first
date you might as well take a catalog of
your cats with you i mean it's just a
horrible idea
don't do it let's here's how a dude
thinks about dating all right first
thing they want to connect
second they got to figure out if they
like you third if they like you then we
hope they start to dig you all right so
that's next level from like they dig you
they want to spend more time then they
commit and then finally love so this i'm
just breaking this i just wrote down
connect like
hannah hannah you need to know right in
front of him coleman
i got it it's his list i got it because
yeah you need to know this this is how
dudes think and so
when we get to commit that's four so let
me review for all the single ladies
connect the dude's got to connect with
him then they got you got to get him to
like you
then you want him to dig you and then
you want him to commit
when we get to commit this is level four
james i just made up this this
unbelievable knowledge right here on the
spot you're such a preacher's kid what's
that such a preacher's kid well it's
just true i just laid it out right here
when we get to level four commit
then we start talking about
hey what are your views on money see how
i'm spinning this from a little bit of
fun to serious totally now we start
going hey
how did your parents handle money when
you grow up maybe you buy rachel cruz's
book maybe you do and and you say i read
this book know yourself know your money
and you talk about
it and how you see money here's another
thought hannah and then we'll let you
know i didn't get to finish oh i'm so
sorry so that's the last piece if you
find out that he's on opposite worlds a
party like he's totally opposite of you
on money now you can start to get
nervous and go hey here's how i see
money this could be a major divide are
you and if we see if he's willing to
then
make some changes there you go go ahead
i'm trying to i was trying to plug your
classrooms and
all the things
because it's wonderful it actually is a
wonderful way to talk about money well
that's all i was going to say is a lot
of these conversations
could be in your unproven uh five-step
plan number three oh right here
that a part of oh you're moving it up
what okay but i'm being honest as you're
in a relationship and this could be a
romantic relationship this could be even
just a friendship but when you start to
really
understand people and know them on a
deeper level
and what makes them who they are
those conversations is what
it's going to make you know them dig you
slash you dig them yeah and part of that
is hey here's like how i see the world
and here's how i view things and here's
like oh there's a family over there with
kids let's judge them and figure out how
i would do different you know in
parenting style like like understanding
someone on a on a depth level i would
say the way money is handled the way you
view money how it acts in your life
is possibly in level three it's i'm okay
with that because i just made it up i'm
willing to move her but but i think we
don't want to do it in the connect and
the likes yeah so hannah that's that's
your answer sorry that was a very long
no it was wonderful that was a circle
but i don't know that anybody's ever
gotten that depth of advice on dating
and money talk at the same time that was
wonderful yes it's really really good
hannah but i think it's awesome and also
hannah your question sorry i'm going to
keep going because we have two we have
one more minute we can't take another
caller in one minute okay
is that it's out of her fear yeah that's
what she said she's terrified how do i
bring it up well and she doesn't want to
get with a guy exactly exactly and so
fear i don't think is the best motivator
in life i think it's a great motivator
at times i agree with you but let that
fear understand why why is that your
fear hannah is it because you want to
feel
provided you want to feel connected like
understanding that why the fear drives
you
that's going to help also to unpack and
try to kind of pinpoint who you want you
can call you can call me dr joan deloney
yeah i like that i like that but let me
you know what what's what else is is
important i think to point out get your
quick perspective
you don't want to go into it feeling
like you got to find the guy who agrees
with you lockstep on everything
certainly not money sure they may not
have any education they may not have the
knowledge that she has she's been
working baby steps since the beginning
of the year she's already baby step
three so give folks some grace be
patient with them hey they might believe
in the baby steps but if they don't know
it don't discount him because he's got
credit card debt